what's going on everybody welcome to
another P game tutorial video in this
video we're going to be building on the
last video in our sort of like
miniseries in P game about how to make
buttons in P game so um the way that
we're going to give the feel of an
interactive button is by having the
button change color as we hover it so
this is something that happens with like
URLs right you have um you hover the
mouse over URL and it underlines itself
and sometimes it changes color um so
this gives the idea to somebody or gives
the impression to somebody that hey this
is interactive maybe we can click it and
so that's how what we're going to do
with our buttons as well and actually a
lot of buttons um have like hover um
attributes to them um as a part of the
CSS so uh that's what we're going to do
people seem to find this um
understandable as a clickable thing you
know if it if it lights up so
um that's what we're going to do so
we'll come down here we've got our
buttons oh and and since we want to make
it a lighter color we have to define the
lighter colors so here we've got red and
green um I'm going to make red a little
darker and since we're using RGB it's
based on light so how would we make make
red darker well we would take away some
light so red will be 200 now and then
we're going to Define brightcore red and
then oops uh write underscore green
equals
equals and a bright red would be
255 and a bright green would be 0
255 easy enough now we'll come down to
our game intro and we're going to make
these buttons um
interactive so how would how will we
make them interactive first of all again
a computer doesn't know that like oh
he's over that green block you know it
doesn't know that but what we can do is
we can inform of it inform it that we
are and as you saw with the events it's
it's printing out the position of our
Mouse constantly so we can grab that
information so first of all how do we
grab that so we'll just say mouse equals
and this is py game. mouse.
getor
position and and Just for kicks let's go
ahead and print Mouse and see what it
says and then also I'm going to go ahead
and comment out the print events that
way we can see it um so we'll save and
run that and you can see here that it is
going crazy printing out this tupal
about the location of the mouse so no
matter where our Mouse is it's giving us
a tupal of the X and Y location so how
might we bring this button lighter bring
it to light well anytime our our Mouse
is within the coordinates of this box we
we can know that by visiting this number
so when it is we since we're drawing in
frames per second we can light up the
box use a lighter color to draw the box
and it'll appear as if the box is
interactive in some form or fashion so
we'll close out of this and come back
down here there's our Mouse we'll just
we don't need to print it out every time
so I'm just going to comment that out
and then we ask the
question
um if we're going to have an if
statement and it just needs to be in
between the X and the X plus the width
and the Y and the Y plus the width and
as long as the two positions are within
those values then we're within the box
so um let's just write it out because
that might sound confusing but if
150 so if the x coordinate plus the um
let's see
150 Plus 100 so if the x coordinate plus
the width if that is greater than the
mouse position zero so the x value so if
our x value of the mouse is greater or
is less
than um 150 plus 100 so that's like the
right side of the Box while that while
that exp position of our Mouse is
simultaneously greater than 150 which is
the x
coordinate um we're doing good so far
now we would just say if that's the case
and uh for 50 + 50 right the Y location
plus 50 so like the bottom of our box is
greater than the mouse location um of
the first element or first element so
the Y of our Mouse with when it is s
simultaneously greater than just
straight up the Y so between the top and
the bottom of the Y then it just so
happens that we are within the
boundaries of our uh uh box so we would
draw this as um bright green I'm just
going to leave that there for now we'll
edit that to bright green in just a
moment if that's the case um it would be
bright green and then L's
if it's not within all of those uh
parameters then we'll just draw it as
green so this need this green becomes a
bright
green and that should be it so now when
we save and run
this we have our game here and you can
see that now when we hover over our
little button here it it lights up as we
hover over it and again it's not like
the button is really interactive but it
it's starting to feel somewhat
Interactive because of this illusion
that we're giving the user so um now
what's left for us to do with this
button well we need to put some text on
the button and then the button needs to
actually do something when we click on
the button uh this is both of these
things are easy enough but the other
major thing that we need to do is we
want to actually build a button function
because right now our our you know code
is already basically this big you know
we could ignore some of these empty
lines but I mean we've got a decent
amount of code piling up here and at the
end of the day it would be better to
just have a function where we call like
button what does the button say where is
the button period and then or like what
does the button do so we're going to
have to add all of that stuff so anyway
in the next video uh I think we'll
probably throw text on here and then
after that we'll make the button
function so to speak but um that's what
you guys have to look forward to so as
always thank you for watching thanks for
all of the support and subscriptions and
until next time